c'est la chenille qui redémarre
en avant les voyageurs et maintenant on
se met à table
comment rendre un voyage culinaire
totalement immersif le youtubeur italien
Luis a décidé de goûter les meilleurs
croissants de Paris en pleine
manifestation le vidéaste au 1,7
millions d'abonnés prend le temps de
décrire l'aspect le goût et la texture
de la viennoiserie sur fond de feu de
poubelle son expérience lui permet de
faire un top 5 des meilleurs
boulangeries rythmées au bruit des
explosions
[Musique]
il a déclaré au Parisien les croissants
meilleurs goût sans le gaz lacrymogène
extrêmement marrant ce gars s'appelle
Louise salle et ce youtubeur a fait ça
juste pour dire qu'il était possible en
fait de kiffer la gastronomie française
en même temps que les luttes sociales
françaises on est célèbre dans le monde
entier pour la Révolution de 1789 et
pour notre gastronomie et il a rendu
hommage aux deux salutations vive mon
puis en poudre ça mouillera moins et
vous savez quoi peut-être que ça va
exister grâce à lycée MDA qui ce matin
nous dit que tout ce qui est liquide et
tout ce qu'on avale au petit déj
notamment tout ça c'est fini bientôt on
fera
exactement tout en poudre quant à toutes
les qualités exactement et vous êtes une
femme très engagée qui déjà donnée du
sens à votre vie car vous avez sauvé
trois poules de la battoir absolument
comment s'appelle-t-elle alors elle
s'appelle Lucienne
tender et nuggets
ça ne manque pas de sel et
je vous en prie regardez
un burger
un épée steak des légumes de la sauce du
fromage un pain brioché
on rappelle que pour avoir de grosses
fesses ou prendre un peu de poids il
faut augmenter ses apports en protéines
ça veut dire manger du poisson de la
viande ou encore des légumineuses et si
vous faites de la musculation c'est
protéines vont être transformées en
muscles on peut donc être ce qu'on
appelle une skinny et avoir de grosses
fesses en faisant de la musculation et
mangeant des lentilles pas besoin
d'aller à la pharmacie pour prendre des
médicaments est-ce que je pourrais
demander à Cruella la phrase précédente
alors vous savez quoi il y a même que ça
a demandé à cruel c'est un deuxième
moment mythique pour moi
d'entendre sa voix
je reviens des cabinets justement
alors la phrase d'avant
de cette blague si elle s'y met aussi là
le projet le plus abouti vous le
connaissez bien il a été présenté en
2020 par des chercheurs de l'Université
de Stanford aux États-Unis voilà à quoi
ressemble la cuvette qui les ont imaginé
elle est munie de capteurs d'images de
bandelettes urinaires de détecteur de
mouvements mais également de petites
caméras
[Applaudissements]
ces équipements ils sont miniaturisés
évidemment ils vont donc recueillir les
informations qu'ils sont liées au sel et
aux urines les transmettent très très
vite à des professionnels pour analyses
et que ce soit donc détectée
éventuellement des pathologies je
précise que cette cuvette elle est
capable de reconnaître et de distinguer
qui qui s'assoit dessus c'est un peu
l'équivalent de la reconnaissance
faciale voilà vous avez compris l'idée
histoire
j'ai un vrai problème avec les nouvelles
technologies
déjà quelques années j'ai dit que
j'avais un vrai problème avec les jeux
électroniques
et on dit jeux vidéo
mais un peu et mes enfants
parce que moi je pense que je suis
encore un peu câblé comme dirait
Mitterrand
des caméras de surveillance équipées
d'un système de reconnaissance faciale
donc pour repérer les femmes non voilées
dans les lieux publics et même dans les
voitures c'est une première en Iran
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes chez vous
alors si vous êtes curieux si vous
ouvrez la porte normalement il y a une
équipe de télé derrière avec une caméra
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez continuer à
Lyon ok et vous avez d'autres choses à
me dire de très intéressantes
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
l'idée que le gouvernement américain
savait que des terroristes s'y préparer
et les algues délibérément laissés faire
un Américain sur trois il souscrit mais
aussi désormais un Français sur quatre
les pseudos extraterrestres de Roswell
obtiennent à peu près le même score et
même la vieille lune des Américains qui
ne seraient jamais allée sur la lune
trouve à peu près autant d'adeptes de
part et d'autre de l'Atlantique
ah bah excuse
-moi il y a personne et bien vous savez
quoi Dominique je crois que de
journalistes se sont trompés de maison
les associations de défense de
l'environnement estiment que chaque
minute 250 kg de plastique serait
déversés dans les océans oui avec des
conséquences à plusieurs niveaux les
particules de microplastiques du
plastique qui va se décomposer
pourraient accélérer le réchauffement
climatique contre un consensus
scientifique solidement établi l'idée
que le réchauffement climatique relève
davantage d'un phénomène naturel que des
activités humaines et partagées par plus
d'un Américain sur 3 et plus d'un
Français sur quatre croyance répandue de
façon relativement homogène même si les
électeurs d'extrême droite sont sur
représentés c'est ce que pensent
41% des sympathisants RN et puis ce
plastique qu'on va retrouver dans la
terre dans la mer va se retrouver aussi
dans l'air et donc dans les poumons dans
nos artères et même dans le lait
maternel
elle est plus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous trouvez 11% des gens en
France pour répondre tranquillement à un
sondage en ligne et pour dire que oui il
est possible que la terre soit plate et
non pas ronde comme on nous le dit
depuis l'école on estime qu'une personne
va ingérer en moyenne 2000 particules de
plastique par semaine alors 2000
particules ça parle pas à tout le monde
ça correspond à 5 g et 5 g c'est une
carte de crédit donc on est ingéré
l'équivalent d'une carte de crédit par
semaine de plastique et encore et
beaucoup pour le moral c'est bon pour le
moral